hello a very good morning to you after a
month of campaigning conservative party
members are expected to receive their
ballot papers this week as they vote to
decide who will become the next prime
minister well tonight liz trust and
rishi sunak will be grueled by tory
voters in a live leadership programme
hosted by kay burley here on sky news
well mr sunak has launched a fresh
attack on miss truss's plans for tax
cuts saying they'll further drive up
interest rates
but he's been criticized too with his
former ally sajid javid saying his plans
risk the uk
sleepwalk walking into a high-tax low
growth economy
so let's bring in our political
correspondent amanda a cass now so
big debate tonight here on sky news
between these two leadership contenders
so what's the state of play as they go
into that debate well another day
another poll really reinforcing liz
truss's lead over rishi sunak so this
latest survey comes from conservative
homes suggesting 58
of party members are backing the foreign
secretary compared to 26 percent for the
former chancellor only 12 still
undecided and those kind of margins are
really similar to the polling we saw
yesterday
from yougov as well another big blow
last night for rishi sunak as you say
satya javid coming out with a fairly
ringing endorsement for liz truss with
some quite withering words for mr sunax
tax policies saying it was sleepwalking
the country into becoming a
middle-income economy and in some ways
it's not surprising mr java's own
platform when he was running to be
leader was about cutting taxes but at
the same time two men are quite close
they work together in the treasury and
are seen to have been friends in the
past so it will be a disappointing blow
now this brings the total of leadership
contenders backing liz trust now to five
none of them coming out for mr sunak he
does have a bit of a boost from nigel
lawson the former chancellor in the 80s
in the telegraph who says his trust his
policies uh risk the country going back
into the inflationary spirals we saw of
the 70s and really the economy is the
central issue in the debate we know the
bank of england later are expected to
put interest rates up there's a big
warning from the resolution foundation
that we could see inflation reaching 15
percent and this has given both
candidates a chance to kind of rehash
their key arguments on the economy so
we've got a statement from mr sunak
saying that timing is everything will be
rushed through with tax cuts that's
going to lead to more inflation putting
people's mortgage interest rates up
there's trust saying no we need to cut
taxes now in order to boost the economy
that's clearly what the big topic of
debate will be on tonight on sky news we
know they're going to have the
opportunity to take uh to have been
questioned by those key undecided party
members before being questioned by k
burley um in interviews as well a 90
minute long program for liz trust the
contest clearly is hers to lose at the
moment for rishi sunaka is really
perhaps as the ballots go out to party
members this week the last big throw of
the dice to try and win over some of
those unconvinced voters yeah
fascinating to see how they both handle
it um that's obviously later on tonight
well the the prime minister the next
prime minister will be decided by
conservative party members and they are
who will make up the audience of
tonight's special programme on sky news
our people and politics correspondent
nick martin has been speaking to two of
them who are yet to make up their minds
about which candidate to back
claire greenfield lives in sully hall in
the west midlands and she's a loyal
conservative but the leadership hopefuls
still have some persuading to do if
they're going to get her vote
ahead of this debate where are you
between the the two candidates russia
sonak liz truss
where are you leaning so at the moment
i'm undecided
between
uh rishi and liz
i am leaning towards liz truss more
and so
this debate
will hopefully make up my mind as a
member of the conservative party and i
can
cast my vote with confidence
claire says she has doubts about rishi
sunak's motivations to become pm and liz
truss's recent climb down over her
policy to determine the salaries of
public sector workers based on where
they live
i think he supported the country very
well through covid
however
the thing i don't like about him is the
i do feel he stabbed boris
in the back liz trust i like the fact
that she's been strong on the
international stage
especially against putin however i was
disappointed with this u-turn
and i thought to myself is this
something that's
going to be
a
carry on the previous boris government
u-turning all the time
130 miles north in harrogate sue lumby
is yet to fully decide sue is 71 and a
councillor
i think they're good in that they're
very different we have a very clear view
on what they both they're both they're
both believes they're both directions i
think she's quite direct she's not
polished on camera and i like that i
like that um
i think she's been a very good foreign
secretary generally i would agree with
rishi sooner over the tax situation i
don't think you can keep borrowing but
today in these days with the uk
ukraine crisis and therefore the fuel
crisis and everything else i think
people
poor people just can't take any more
squeezing
so i definitely favor this trust on that
one sue like claire will take her seat
in the audience at the sky news
leadership debate it's the last chance
the candidates will have to persuade
members before voting begins nick martin
sky news
let's stick with the leadership election
and nhs leaders are warning this morning
that neither candidate has yet provided
what they call meaningful long-term
solutions to the challenges facing the
nhs well the nhs confederation has
written to both of the candidates
setting out their concerns and lord
victor adamawali the organization's
chair joins me now a very good morning
to you so first of all tell us a little
bit about these letters that you've sent
to the two leadership candidates what
are you saying in that letter
well we think we've sent a letter to
both the candidates just saying that
my members are really concerned about
summer which is a bit like winter we've
got winter we've got we've got winter in
summer we have three challenges that are
pretty fundamental we have a workforce
challenge a hundred thousand vacancies
in the nhs hundred and
thousand in social care
we have an estate challenge with
crumbling buildings and burial um
equipment
um and we have a social care challenge
again in that we're not
recruiting or paying enough staff to get
people out of hospital or in hospital
which is meaning we've got a backlog of
ambulances working in a e and we can't
move people into hospitals because we
can't move them out of hospitals because
we don't have social care packages
for people once they
when once they're well well enough to
leave hospitals so in some cases we've
got 20 percent of beds taken up with
people who could leave but can't leave
because there's no social care packages
we have a backlog in elective care which
my colleagues are working really hard to
reduce and in fact are making some
inroads even though it's increasing but
the the state of the buildings means
they can't i mean they can't carry out
the operations and we certainly have
long cases where where the roof in the
hospital is causing real problems for
use of electric care surgery and as i
say we have a problem with vacancy now
neither candidate has addressed these
issues full-on
and we need them to be resolved because
if we don't um we can't offer the the
care that people deserve and they pay
for in their taxes so we have a real
problem on top of that we have an
inflation challenge which is wiped out
the very welcome additional funds that
were given to the nhs earlier so what we
need from both candidates is some we
need to level with the public basically
about what is going on what the pub what
the public can expect and what they're
going to do about these short term
actually medium term and long-term
prices in the nhs and social care system
and what do you want to hear from them
apart from addressing the issue
more is it more money that you're after
well i'd like i'd like to first
acknowledge that there is a crisis that
this is really serious nine out of ten
of our leaders are basically saying that
this is this is the worst they've seen
it and it's and it's going to continue i
think you know it's not for me to tell
them how to manage the economy but i do
think we need to be honest with with
with taxpayers about the fact that you
get what you pay for at the end of the
day
and you do we do need a health system
which which actually is a contributor to
the economy if you're waiting for an
operation on your hip your knee your
cancer treatment you're not working if
you're not working when you're not
contributing to the economy and you're
not paying taxes so this is a
significant challenge for the economy a
healthy nation is a working nation if
we're not healthy then we can't work so
what we need is both candidates to be
straight with people about the state of
the nhs and the healthcare system and
actually put forward
incredible ways in which we can resolve
the matter in the medium and long term
the the national insurance rise which
has been debated a great deal in this
leadership a contest
was destined it was money the money that
was raised was destined for the nhs now
rishi sunak is going to keep that rise
liz trust has said that the country
can't afford it the people can't afford
it the cost of living crisis is too
great for people to pay extra taxes
what's your
take on that
well i can tell you what we can't afford
we can't afford an nhs system which is
crumbling and can't treat people
properly so they can't work so we
welcome the additional funds and we
would want that to continue um it's for
the two candidates whoever becomes prime
minister to make the difficult choices
that's why we have uh prime ministers on
our behalf to ensure that the nhs and
social care system is properly funded
but what we do need is is realism we
need them to be real realistic with the
public um it's not about political
records gimmicks it's about saying to
the public this is the state of the
united states and social care system
this is what we're going to have to do
i've yet to be anybody certainly um in
the care health or care system who is
saying you know i'd rather have
a lower tax and no health system i think
i think that's not a credible choice and
i i we look for our leaders to present
us with solutions to these challenges
it's my job to put forward
the real estate of the nhs and the
healthcare system on behalf of my
members
well yes and if we look at the different
candidates liz trust has said that she
will provide the funds necessary she'll
just raise them through a different
means and she's talked about measures
like stripping away certain levels of
management as well
what do you make of the plans that she's
announced so far as far as the nhs is
concerned i don't i don't know that
they're very specific or clear and i'm
not sure that they addressed the
challenge you know the the the issue
here as i've said is that we have 165
000 virtues in social care we have a
hundred thousand frequencies in the nhs
we need a fully custom workforce plan
which actually ensures that we can
employ enough people to care for your
relatives my relatives and members of
our community
they need to be very clear about how
they're going to fund that they need to
be clear about what resources they're
going to make available to fix our
crumbling estate and on our equipment
and the need to ensure that we can pay
social care workers so enough so that we
can find the packages of care that get
put that get people in hospital
we can get people out hospital so we get
desperate people who need divergent care
into hospital so i'd like specific
answers to those
three key questions um one of which we
need to be resolved now i mean the
social care challenge we're simply not
paying social care workers enough to do
the skill jobs necessary to get people
out of hospital and so that we can
actually get ambulance people in the
back of ambulances these aren't people
who are who are uh fantastic people in
desperate need of emergency care in
hospital and who have to wait in the
back of ambulances sometimes for hours
people getting ambulance at all because
the ambulance is uh a rush to the end of
the rush
to the end of their capacity so we need
answers to those specific issues that's
why we've been so clear in the letters
of both candidates
and and could those answers be provided
by a special task force because that's
rishi sunak's plan isn't it to introduce
the task force along the lines of the
covid vaccine task force to try and
address some of these issues do you
welcome that
well i'm all i'm all for task forces and
um and specific interventions but again
they avoid they avoid the answer you
know we know what the answer is to the
social care problem we've said we we
as a membership body don't don't
complain without presenting solutions
the answer to the social care challenge
is to pay people a minimum of 10 pound
50 an hour that means we can actually
attract people into social care or keep
people in social care who are leaving to
get easier jobs in say a resale um or
hospitality industry we know that the
backlog in capital uh building
requirement just requires an injection
of capital money
and we know that the inflationary costs
that are reduced actually reduce the
amount of money available for the nhs
needs an urgent injection of cash to
that right we can do the rest i have
full confidence
in
my colleagues in their leadership
abilities and in the front line of our
nhs and social care system to deliver as
they did during the pandemic what they
need is the resources and the leadership
to enable them to do so so you know i
think
i think
what we need the specific responses i'm
all i will work with whoever
my members will work with whoever
becomes prime minister but what we need
them to be to be doing is to be really
honest about you know these are the
challenges we accept what you're saying
as leaders of the health and social care
system this is what we're going to do
with you
with you to resolve them and we've made
suggestions we we're very clear about
what needs to happen
okay well lord victor adeboye chair of
nhs confederation thanks very much
indeed for joining us this morning
and it'll be interesting to see to what
extent the nhs does come out tonight uh
in sky news's special tory leadership
program it's at eight o'clock this
evening the battle for number 10 will
see the two candidates answer questions
from the live studio audience as well as
an in-depth interview with the host k
burley and there'll be special coverage
from seven o'clock here on sky news and
you can also watch it live on sky news's
website or app or follow on our live
blog
let's take a look now at the stories
that are making the front pages of this
morning's papers and the daily telegraph
understands that plans for a 250 million
pound water plant that's supposed to
ease the burden of hosepipe bands has
been taken out of service
while the star hears that water
companies are encouraging people to
report their neighbours for flouting
those hose pipe bands
according to the express inflation could
hit 15 percent by next year with gas
bills substantially to blame
the daily mail has the attorney general
zoella bravaman again pledging to curb
so-called workism
the mirror features swimmer adam pt
calling on the government to invest more
in children's sports facilities
especially given the lionesses victory
at euro 2022
the guardian carries an investigation
which has found that a far-right
ecosystem is targeting children in the
uk in an attempt to radicalize them
online
so those are your papers this morning
let's tell you what's coming up on the
show later on this hour we'll have our
daily polling pit stop where we'll get
the latest numbers on how the tory
leadership candidates are doing we'll be
speaking to craig watkins chief
executive of kantar public
uk
former leadership candidate and attorney
general zwella braverman will tell us
why she's backing liz truss
and later on we'll speak to personal
finance expert gemma godfrey on what
impact an interest rate rise could have
now archie battersby's life support will
be withdrawn at 11 o'clock this morning
unless his family launches a high court
bid by 9 am to move him to a hospice
something his parents plan to do
it comes after the european court of
human rights refused an appeal to stop
doctors ending life-sustaining hospital
treatment
saying it will not interfere with the
decisions of uk courts skies satya
chowdhury reports
nine court attempts to keep her son
alive arch's mother now faces another on
where he should be when his life support
treatment is ended
it comes after the european court of
human rights decided it cannot intervene
to help
absolutely
deflate is just so let down um
yeah obviously that was our last option
um
with regards to even the fact that
we've been offered
help from other countries you know
they're not even prepared to shift on
that
we've now got a fight to see whether one
get him out of here to have a dignified
passing at a hospice
it's just it's unfair
decisions about her child that are out
of her hands
he's good
he's been good all along that's the most
heartbreaking thing about it
you know i wish i could
take you all in there to see
that for yourself
it's just unfair
the fact is apparent we've got no rights
with our children it's disgusting
holly dance has fought bart's health nhs
trust in a remarkable case that started
with a fight over whether archie should
have a brain stem test to be declared
legally dead
and culminated in legal arguments about
the uk's international treaty
obligations
the hospitals say treatment will end at
11 am today unless the family file an
application at the high court to move
him
they want to take him to a hospice but
sky news understands the trust will
oppose this
it could be the tenth court appearance
for holly dance whose stance had never
changed all she'd asked for was time for
archie to recover
she points to the case of lewis roberts
declared brain stem dead last year but
just hours before his organs were to be
donated
lewis breathed by himself
this is him last week
playing football
i just feel horrendous for the family
or folks it's taken out of their hands
isn't it it's a constant fight and a
battle for them
which really shouldn't be that way
should it
it's absolutely terrible
i can't believe it i was pronounced dad
i really can't pronounce that
a dream come true for one family
unrealized for another sadia chaudhary
sky news in london
the bank of england is expected to
announce the largest interest rate rise
for 27 years in the face of soaring
inflation
well let's get more we can speak to our
correspondent matthew thompson who's in
east london for us now so matthew what
are we expecting then from the bank of
england
well the markets are widely expecting
the bank to raise interest rates by half
a percentage point to 1.75
which would be the biggest single
interest rate hike for almost 30 years
and the sixth consecutive rise in
interest rates and at the same time
we're expecting the announcement of the
beginning of the winding down of the
vast program of quantitative easing as
it's called which has seen the bank
acquire some
895 billion pounds worth of guilts and
corporate bonds since the beginning of
the financial crisis and together those
two things really represent the biggest
step yet away from the era of cheap and
easy money that we've become used to
over the last
10 years or so and the reason for that
well it's the specter of soaring
inflation which is already expected to
hit 11 percent by the end of this year
and if you consider that the bank of
england's target for inflation is just 2
well then you can see why they think
they need to take some action the
trouble is that raising interest rates
is not without its risk it will
immediately increase borrowing costs for
millions of people particularly the two
million or so people who are on
variable or
tracker rate mortgages in the middle of
a cost of living crisis it will as i say
push up borrowing costs for lots of
people there's also a risk
incidentally that it will tip the entire
country into a recession you have to
imagine if you suck so much demand out
of the economy then that is a real and
potential risk in fact overnight there's
a survey by ipsos which has shown that
two-thirds of people in the uk are
concerned about rising interest rates
the trouble really for the bank is that
the risks of doing nothing and letting
inflation soar are just as bad if not
worse as the risks of doing something
raising interest rates and risking a
recession in the middle of a course of
living crisis indeed matthew thanks very
much indeed
let's take a look at some of those other
headlines now and a man has been charged
with the murder of 32 year old claire
holland who went missing in bristol a
decade ago ms holland was last seen
leaving a pub in the city center on the
evening of june 2012 and has not been
seen or heard from since forty-year-old
darren osmond will appear before bristol
magistrates court later today
the murder of a missing student nurse
has made an emotional appeal for
information as police release these new
cctv images
24 year old awami davis has been missing
since leaving her home in grades in
essex on the 4th of july nicole davis
says she believes that someone has
information on her daughter's
whereabouts
campaigners say that more needs to be
done to support young people and prevent
suicides after the government announced
further funding for student mental
health services the student mines mental
health charity has received a three-year
funding commitment to extend the
provision of student space
england's line essays have written an
open letter to tory leadership
candidates rishi sunak and liz trust
demanding that all school girls have
access to a minimum of two hours a week
in sports classes the euro 2022 winners
warned that women's football has come a
long way but it still has a long way to
go
now china is conducting military drills
off the coast of taiwan after saying
that it would begin a series of live
fire exercises today it comes after u.s
house speaker nancy pelosi's visit to
the island angered beijing well this
morning taiwan says that several
governmental agencies have been hit by
cyber attacks
well let's get more on this now diviane
gopalan is the international editor of
taiwan plus and joins me now
so tell us a little bit more about
what's happened in the wake of nancy
pelosi's visit then
that's right china warned that the
people's liberation army would not stand
idly by and they would take action and
this is what they're doing about 20
minutes after nancy pelosi first landed
on taiwan soil china announced these
military exercises now it's not unusual
for china to have such activities when
there are dignitaries in
taiwan especially high-level foreign
dignitaries but this time the kind of
exercises they are planning and they
have planned and have started they say
is unprecedented in fact chinese state
media says they've lost already launched
a long-range missile into the eastern
waters of the taiwan strait they say
that start of their firing ex that's the
start of their firing exercise and this
precedes some activity overnight where
drones passed over kinman island that's
part of taiwan's territory which is
about 10 kilometers away from mainland
china and uh taiwan's military had to
fire flares to try to deter them now
kidman island is
believed to be or said to be the first
point of attack should china choose to
invade taiwan so it's a very sensitive
area there so yes china has already
started it's
these large-scale military exercises
around the waters here that the ministry
of defense have said it amounts to a
blockade of taiwan they've asked for
shipping routes to be changed aviation
routes to be uh to be also moved around
because it poses a great danger to
anyone who could be in the path of those
long-range or even possible short-range
naval missiles that would be hitting
taiwan's territorial waters
vivio gopalan thanks very much indeed
for that update
now liz trust has received a fresh boost
in her bid to become the next
conservative leader as she and rival
rishi sunak prepare to face the cameras
on sky news this evening
a fresh poll suggests the gap between
the foreign secretary and former
chancellor is widening in favor of
mistrust and here to pick apart the
numbers is our polling pit stop in our
polling pit stop is chief executive of
kantar public uk a very good morning to
you let's take a look through your poll
new polling shows a lot of the countries
still haven't made all that my mind's on
the best leadership candidate in their
view that's right we've got um i mean
our latest poll shows that nearly 50
percent of of the british public are
still undecided um and then with rishi
and and liz it's kind of split equally
if you look beneath those figures at
tory voters actually liz is in front
with 45 percent while rishi sunak has 31
the tory party members are the ones who
vote are a much smaller kind of
constituency so you get kind of further
um refinements of that but at the moment
for tory voters
this trust is is in the lead but for the
general public most people are still
undecided yeah they look they didn't
very evenly split there don't they and
but one thing the public seem to be
relatively
agreeing on is the need for a general
election that seems to be one of their
their views that's coming forward in
your poll yeah that's and that's
something we've seen growing over the
last couple of months is you know over
50 percent of the population saying that
we should have a general election and we
might see that as wanting to give a
fresh mandate to a new government
whomever that is um the when you again
when you go beneath the figures
overwhelmingly labor voters 78 what a
general election that's perhaps not
unsurprising
50 percent of tory voters don't want um
you know a kind of a general election so
but there's still a sizable portion of
the population who who want to see
um
the kind of the general public given
that opportunity to make that decision
and what about what people want from
their new leader what are we learning
about that
it's very clear
and it was interesting you had the
segment previously around the nhs
increasing capacity in the nhs is always
in in the in the top two of our polling
i mean it's it's
an ever increasing concern um with
reports of waiting lists and the
pressures growing the economy again
unsurprising
six out of ten people are telling us
that they are more worried about the
economy than they were back in january
and six out of ten people are finding it
harder to meet their bills reducing
taxes is there but interestingly for
tory voters
reducing taxes is not their third
priority it's controlling immigration
reducing taxes is a far is is less of a
priority for tory voters than we might
think and this trust
pulling ahead in terms of the tory
voters as we were saying but what about
her policies how are they going down
so it's it's you know there's a lot of
um
discussions around reducing the size and
the cost of the civil service
renegotiating with with the northern
ireland um agreement with the eu you
know kind of like quite hard-nosed
policies
when we ask the public again it's grow
the economy reduce the cost of living
increase capacity in the nhs
and the action that we're seeing people
want is very direct take at our fuel
reduce fuel duty it's those direct
interventions that people are telling us
that they want to see
very interesting be interesting to see
if some of that comes up in the
questions in tonight's debate uh craig
watkins appreciate your time thanks very
much thank you
welcome back the two remaining
candidates in the race for number 10
will tonight face conservative party
members in a live leadership program
here on sky news now last night they
also faced members at a hustings in
cardiff so let's take a listen
we will be able to take on the plastic
patriot secure stammer
and we will be able to take on
the low energy version of jeremy corbyn
that is mark drakeford
and we will win we will win my friends i
passionately believe and all the
evidence supports it that i am the
candidate that offers our party the best
opportunity to win
everywhere and ensure that kirstalma
does not walk through the doors of
number 10 downing street at the end of
that election
so how optimistic are the foreign
secretaries supporters feeling well
let's get the view now of one of them
the attorney general suela brothman who
joins me now very good morning to you
good morning let me just start by asking
you about an article you've written in
today's daily mail you've
got pretty angry in that article about
what you describe as the woke orthodoxy
of diversity equality and inclusion and
you're particularly aiming your fire at
diversity officers and training
but doesn't diversity benefit
institutions like the civil service
i'm all for a diverse workforce i'm all
for meritocracy i'm all for inclusion
those are good things in our society in
britain as a real champion of those
values what i've been very dismayed by
however is the takeover by hr teams by
campaign groups which have propagated a
political ideology when it comes to
identity politics and that's what my
article is about we've seen thousands of
hours a huge cost to the taxpayers spent
on diversity and inclusion training and
it's been divisive not inclusive it's
been patronizing not empowering it's
based on an assumption that me as a an
ethnic asian woman from working-class
roots must be a victim necessarily
oppressed that's a misassumption and i
think it creates division it creates uh
it's tearing the society tearing up our
society breaking down the fabric of our
country and i think it's a waste of
money but the supporters would say
they're exactly what's needed to promote
the diversity you say is so badly needed
no i disagree i think the way it's
taught and the way it's trained is uh
indoctrinating i think that it's uh
written the training materials that i've
seen uh used in the civil service
is riddled with left-wing
views on race and gender things like
white privilege civil servants are
taught about microaggressions
they're taught about white fragility
they're taught about how to be a
straight ally i don't think those are
objectively
impartial when it comes to politics and
i don't think they're good value for
money and i don't think ultimately
that's what taxpayers want their civil
servants or their government lawyers to
be spending their time on your attorney
general how important do you think that
equality laws and anti-discrimination
practices are oh wholly important
absolutely this country has made massive
strides in the field of uh equality and
human rights and that was a really proud
record on supporting people who have
been uh you know had grievances in in
society and in the workplace we've got a
very good track britain is one of the
best places in the world to be
a woman to be an ethnic minority to be a
gay person we have a great record on
rights and equalities let's champion
that not let's not keep creating
division but does this not send out the
wrong message then if we want to
champion that and are you concerned that
there are reports that members of the
lgbt plus conservative group are
questioning their future in the party
because of this anti-woke message not at
all i think actually the conservative
party has an enviable track record we're
the party that introduced and legislated
for same-sex marriage something that i
would have voted for something i'm very
very proud of in this country and that
it was a conservative prime minister
and an er that led the way on that uh i
think that we're very inclusive
in our party uh and actually our recent
leadership campaign demonstrates the
modern diverse meritocratic conservative
party that we are we're a party in which
whatever your personal characteristic
it's about the tal your talent and your
ability to do the job that really counts
i mean is a move like this going to be
even popular you've said that it's it's
going to be money saving you talked
about it being 12 million pounds of
saving but the latest poll that we've
been talking about this morning says
just six percent of britain's think that
reducing the size of the civil service
should be a priority this isn't even a
vote winner is it
well it's not really about being a vote
winner this is about making government
work well for the british people but
you're trying to appeal to the public
aren't you
well we've got to do our job we've got
to deliver on our manifesto commitments
and we've got to do that in the best
possible way in uh with the best value
for money and the civil service is too
large we are bloated and that's why this
prime minister and uh both leadership
candidates have been supportive of
reducing the size and state liz trust
incidentally has been very very strong
on trying to cut out waste in whitehall
cut out
the quangos reduce the regulations
reduce the diversity and inclusion
training which doesn't really serve a
material but the point i'm making is the
polls suggest that people generally
don't think it should be a huge priority
they might say the cost of living is a
huge priority for them by contrast and
at the time when we're we're going
through that and also there are tensions
overseas as well you've chosen to write
an article in the mail
which is anti-woke is that really your
biggest priority i wouldn't necessarily
describe it as anti-work actually i'd
say it's uh against uh identity policy
officers
and uh it's against identity politics
and the divisive nature of uh of this uh
this trend that we're seeing in our
corporate and public sector but uh i'll
just mention
this issue of the day that's why you
chose now but i think it's the biggest
issue today i think the biggest issue of
the day is how we support families and
businesses with the cost of living uh
and that's why when uh that's been the
priority of this campaign for the leader
of the party and it's uh by far the most
important issues how we take a muscular
stance against vladimir putin it's about
how we deliver uh public services but
what what's important about this civil
service issue is that when it comes to
issuing passports on time when it comes
to getting people's driving licenses to
them in a in a prompt nature it comes to
civil service efficiency it comes to
government delivery and if we can reduce
the cost of civil service to reduce the
cost of government that's only not not
only good for the economy um and public
uh spending it's also really good for
efficiency and public service delivery
for uh individuals okay you say that the
economy is is one of your priorities and
liz truss's priority is well the bank of
england is expected to put up interest
rates today possibly as much as by half
of one percent that would be the biggest
rise for 27 years liz trust has made a
lot of spending commitments she wants to
cut taxes to the tune of around 30
billion pounds she says she'll pay for
that through economic growth are you
worried that higher interest rates will
dampen that growth and she won't be able
to pay for these promises no interest
rates should have been raised a long
time ago and the bank of england has
been too slow in this regard uh interest
rates have a really important
gravitational pull
on uh the value of assets and it's
really important to curb inflation so
actually it's very welcome that the bank
of england is increasing interest rates
now but what we really need to do and
this is why liz it has got the right
plan for dealing with the cost of living
challenges is that we've got to ensure
that we review the bank of england's
mandate she's very interested in looking
at how the bank of england operates
maintaining its independence of course
but also ensuring that it's much better
placed and more responsive
in the future to economic challenges
like this like the type we're seeing at
the moment the the challenge that we're
facing at the moment is the fight
against global inflation raising
interest rates is a lever that the bank
of england has in that fight reducing
public spending is another and cutting
taxes so that families and businesses
can grow their way out of the challenges
as is is a very important step forward
and that's why liz is the standout
candidate for me because she's
forthright on the absolute need to cut
taxes but cutting taxes is inflationary
cutting taxes is going to be very
important for families so uh when we
look at the customers i'm sure that
right many families will be welcoming
the idea of tax cuts but it'll allow
them to spend more money it's inflation
well not necessarily because actually
what we're going to see if we do lower
the tax burden don't forget we've got
the highest tax burden in 70 years uh
people say we can't afford to cut taxes
liz thinks and i agree with her that we
can't afford not to cut taxes uh if we
cut taxes we're going to free up
businesses to invest more in their
research and development employ more
people um lower their costs and that's
only going to be good for the economy
they're going to generate more revenue
to the exchequer that's going to
generate more economic growth and
therefore we have more to invest in our
public services cutting taxes is the
necessary step to take and that's why
liz is the right person to lead us
through these economic challenges
another quick bit of detail on the bank
of england how are you going to reform
the bank of england you want you want to
get them more power you want to get them
fewer powers i'm confused well the liz
trust has made clear that she wants to
review the mandate that the bank of
england so what does that have so that's
going to be looking in detail at exactly
what the bank of england does and see
whether it's actually fit for purpose in
terms of its uh entire uh exclusionary
independence over interest rates the
last time this was done was in 1997 it's
right and it's ripe now to review
whether that is the right settlement
when it comes to
our monetary policy of course that's not
to take away the bank of england's
independence but there are very uh there
are many other models around the world
where central banks have different uh
degrees of independence over monetary
policy for example japan is a country
which we're looking and i know that liz
is very very keen on radical reform to
ensure that monetary policy can be much
better uh placed and more responsive to
uh to
to inflationary pressures but also
economic challenges the nhs
confederation we spoke to the chairman
this morning has sent letters to liz
trust and rishi sunag
calling on them to spend more time on
that campaign talking about the health
service why has this been so absent from
liz truss's campaign why is this not
been a big priority well i don't think
it has been absent i think uh having
watched uh some of the debates uh and
hustings uh between liz and rishi i
think it's
almost always come up as a question
but not necessarily policies forthcoming
on that subject and this trust is
abandoning the national insurance rise
the money was supposed to go towards the
health service well again i mean this is
about a combination of uh stewardship of
our economy in a responsible way so
cutting taxes as we talked about earlier
but also delivery of public services and
liz is absolutely clear that we are
going to stand by our 2019 manifesto
commitments so the new hospitals
ensuring that people get access to a gp
face-to-face ensuring that there is
better patient flow through our a e by
enabling better primary care
and reforming social care we all know
well many of us know that it's painful
uh it's heartbreaking and it's
incredibly difficult these days if
you've got an elderly relative and
you're trying to navigate the care uh
the labyrinthine process of getting a
continuing health care package it
shouldn't be that way and that's why
liz will be introducing
major reforms to ensure that there's
more equity when it comes to
affording social care for elderly
relatives but also enabling better
delivery of primary care so that is a an
absolute non-negotiable basic uh tenant
of liz's campaign okay and and um i do
want to get you um to
get your views on a subject as attorney
general um about archie battersby um the
12 year old his family been fighting to
keep him on life support his mother
holly dance said last night it feels
wrong that the court of appeal have
taken away our rights
do parents in this country in your view
have enough rights when it comes to the
care of their children
well first of all i must just put on
record my deepest uh sympathies
for the family of archie battersby i
cannot begin to imagine what
he and his family have been going
through um
this is a an incredibly uh heartbreaking
situation and everybody is watching uh
as uh the the parents and the family try
uh relentlessly to uh look after and do
the best by their son any parent i'm
sure would try to do the same this has
been this has gone through the english
courts
and a decision was made by our supreme
court a few days ago not to grant
permission to appeal um and uh following
that
as i understand that the family applied
to the european court of human rights to
seek an intervention from the strasbourg
court that was declined by the european
court of human rights it's not for me to
uh look behind those decisions of
independent courts but of course this is
heartbreaking this is incredibly sad and
my thoughts go to the family but but as
a general rule
aside from this case do parents have
enough rights over the care of their
children do you think i think generally
we have a very important balance to
strike in this country
i think generally yes parents do have
sufficient rights it's the legal
presumption is that parents are acting
in the best interest of their children
until and or unless proved otherwise
and i think that generally the best
interests of the child are the guiding
theme in any of these decisions and
parents will be best placed uh to
understand what the best interest of
their child in in highly complex uh both
legally and morally
issues like these ones there are very
many different competing factors like
medical opinion um and the value of uh
clinical intervention that has to be
weighed against the the parents wishes
as well and many other factors in
in these cases these are not
straightforward they're highly highly
complex matters involving uh detailed
issues of medicine and medical ethics
as well as the child's welfare
and i have confidence that our courts
and our judges will have looked at these
issues incredibly thoroughly incredibly
sensitively and have reached the the
right decision
and finally before i let you go let me
just quickly ask you about tonight's
debate on sky news what can we expect
from liz trust what does she have to do
listen i'm incredibly proud and excited
to be supporting liz to be the leader of
our party and the next prime minister
she's proven time and time again that
she's experienced that she delivers and
that she's got a bold and bright vision
for our united kingdom
she is
performing incredibly well i was just
speaking to party members yesterday
evening
about liz's candidature the response is
very very positive
people are coming to liz in their droves
um not just mps but also um memphis
debate what will we see from that very i
think we're going to see typical liz
we're going to see bright bold uh
exciting liz who can who is going to set
out a uh a bold vision for our country
supporting families and businesses with
the cost of living cutting taxes taking
a firm stance uh on brexit promises and
delivering for the country okay so ella
braverman thanks very much indeed for
coming in we appreciate it
now then as we were discussing there the
bank of england is set to make what's
forecast to be the biggest hike in
interest rates for 27 years in the face
of soaring inflation hundreds of
thousands of people could see their
mortgages and loan repayments jump by
hundreds of pounds
so let's get more on this and get the
thoughts of the personal finance expert
gemma godfrey who joins us now so gemma
godfrey first of all explain to us
why the bank of england might make this
move
well the bank of england has a really um
tough challenge where they're trying to
control inflation but they don't want to
tip us into recession so what we've been
hearing for the past few months is that
our economy has been slowing down we're
not spending as much companies aren't um
aren't selling as much and that
obviously risks jobs but obviously
everybody is aware that our everyday
living costs are rising they're rising
by five times um they're set to rise by
more than five times as much as the the
target that the bank of um england sets
and it's a war on all fronts it's food
it's energy you know people are really
really struggling so the bank of england
will try and increase rates to try and
slow this down um but obviously there's
there's calls that they've been too slow
um they're being or they're being too
aggressive and it's a very very tough
balancing act for for many millions of
families around the uk
well yeah so how will people feel the
impact if this rate rise does go ahead
will they see prices falling quite
quickly if it happens
no the the problem is that there's a lag
so the the bank of england will raise
interest rates fine and this is going to
be the sixth interest rate rise in a row
to put it in context rates were at a
historical low before that so it is
actually expected that the bank of
england could continue to raise interest
rates but the effect that we see is more
of an immediate um hardship on people
that are borrowing so um borrowing rates
will be going up so obviously variable
mortgages will be hit immediately um and
you know be harder for first-time buyers
and it'll be harder for people that you
know are borrowing money on credit cards
for example but in terms of the positive
impact so the impact in terms of um for
savers to get a better interest rate on
their savings or for prices to fall that
takes a lot longer and that's why it's
really really tricky for the bank of
england to make this move because in the
very very short term what it does the
immediate effect is it just makes
borrowing more expensive at a time when
it's more expensive to feed your family
to keep them warm to transport and to
travel to your job
so any tips for how people should manage
this if they're looking at interest
rights
interest rates going up what should they
do with their money
i mean it is one of the toughest times i
usually like to come on the show and
come and say here's three or four
different you know very easy tips and i
mean the first thing to say is that many
families are really really struggling
and so the first big tip is to speak up
is that there are you know energy
suppliers banks you know that really the
earlier you can speak to them and agree
um a payment plan the better because
what you want to do is avoid penalties
and most of all you want to avoid going
more into debt because debt is going to
be getting more and more expensive as
interest rates go up so
there is actually something that the
regulator has said that energy providers
need to do which is to provide an
affordable payment plan um and a lot of
energy providers have hardship funds
free support services as well um there's
retailers are offering discounts if you
want to donate um clothes that you don't
use anymore there's websites to help
check to see whether you're okay buying
the cheapest petrol though don't travel
too far to to go to those places um
yellow ticket items at um supermarkets
can also help you buy things like okay
we're out of time but brilliant advice
gemma i'm sorry to cut in but we must
say goodbye thanks so much for all your
tips